yeah so um i'm paola um i i work at
spice it's a
coding academy and i am the head of data
science and i lead data science coach
and today i'm not going to talk about my
work at spice
um i have a talk for you that i've
called your first thousand words
say more than a thousand words
and i hope you get
the meaning of it um after the talk
um
yeah so
i
like my job like my day job a lot yeah
um
reasons eyes are that i love working
with data in all forms and
running a 12-week bootcamp where we do
all broad things from
pandas to dog care and everything in
between
is
very rewarding it also keeps me
learning all the time and one of the
reasons i love
teaching so much is because i learned so
much
um
but one of the things i realized just
when i started
doing this for a longer time is that i
also watch other people learn
so it's not that i like
learning and teaching but it's this
process of seeing people being empowered
by the new things
they can do
um
these are the reasons i love my daytime
job
and
meanwhile
and my
other job
yeah in my other job
things look more
like this so i am the mom of a toddler i
am the tired mom of a toddler
and there are many reasons why i also
love
this job but surprisingly or not
surprisingly also many overlap with my
um with my day job yeah i have i am
learning a lot
i am teaching a lot
um if if i like it or not kids just
learn from
what you do with with how you behave
um
but maybe the most fascinating thing
of being a mum of a very small small
child is watching
others learn yeah watching this little
creature
learn
the the basic basic things and it's
funny because i find
myself in my courses often comparing
where we're doing machine learning
comparing with how
the little little little human mind
really
starts recognizing or misrecognizing
patterns etc
so
one of the um
the most beautiful things is watching
this obviously and
on the on the terms of data i've
although i'm known for actually
like gathering personal data for my for
for my person for projects
i had been taking
slowly or doing nothing with regards to
my kid i didn't want to
get a lot of data or gather a lot of
data from my kid
um that changed
the moment something started to happen
when he was around
nine months old
and he started
producing words yeah first was
mom then go out there and these are like
one month in between yeah and then
other words started appearing quickly
and
at that time i thought well this is nice
and also because i am i mean my
background is in natural sciences but
i've been
a hobby linguist for a while because for
around 15 years i've been
in contact or helping with um
the analysis and visualization of
linguistic research so
i i know interesting data when when i
see it and
so i started gathering those words
i had
had the word and a time stamp i think i
will start collecting those words
and after i had
a thousand
this
project
came alive this project of analyzing the
kids
language acquisition
um i gathered the the words manually
yeah in a spreadsheet app from my phone
and i was collecting always the date
the work and
the language
because as you might see or not see
because the banana is
not blended in
um
we are in a bilingual environment in the
family so
most of the words aren't in spanish or
in german
so it took
17 months to gather a thousand words
from
when he was nine months old to
almost
more than two to one a couple of months
and then i had this
simple table really just thousand words
that i could analyze with um
the usual
the usual
python data science tools plus stacy
which is something that i was using for
a whole project for the first time
now
this process of language acquisition
is and i might have to um
sorry
take down the camera
somewhere here or so
yeah perfect
um
so
the the purse of language acquisition
um is that some more or less complex one
yeah you have the sounds yeah you have
to be able to do
sounds
or science i'm i'm i'm speaking here of
a spoken language
then you start gaining vocabulary then
you have to learn how to combine these
words and use different kinds of works
and also cover
a space of meaning and that's
that's semantics and all of this i'm
talking about
is an actual field of research in the
field of so-called first language
acquisition that's not not only language
acquisition
but first language
acquisition and when i started getting
the words i thought i was concentrating
on the vocabulary i mean i wanted to say
how the escape
was increasing in
its vocabulary over time
and this is the first thing i took a
look at
uh
vocabulary increased
over
months
and
this confirmed my feeling that at the
beginning was really easy to track the
words yeah it was like one month one
word second one or two more words and at
some time
he started producing several words
daily yeah so that i really
um were really
stressed at some point collecting those
words uh properly
when i followed that i i saw this very
clear uh click her elbow
at around
17 months
and talking to my linguistic friend
because i actually have a very very good
friend who happened to be a linguist and
that's why i the one i do listening with
six projects with ignoring this one's
like real linguistics projects with
um
she explained to me this is like a real
thing
called the vocabulary spur
and it's defined as an acceleration in
the rate at which children acquire
new words
usually between 18 and in 24 months and
this also happens more or less when when
children have like 50 or 100 words so
they start gathering this 5200 words and
then
starts starts exploding
this was pretty cool already to see to
see this pattern that research
knows um in the data
um but then i thought okay so i mean
this is a total amount of word but this
kid is learning words and is saying some
in in in spanish and in german
so i took a look at that yeah so in the
very top you have the whole
um
whole
growth of total warts and in the other
graphs you have the
the number of new spanish words and new
german words per month
um
and you see that the beginning
started growing uh more or less uh
slowly but then there are some facts
the other thing that you need to know uh
here apart that it's a bilingual
environment well it's a couple of things
first
both parents
understand both spanish and german and
both parents speak
spanish and german also
i speak smoothly spanish
my wife speaks mostly german because
that's
our mother tongues but we both
understand both and the kid knows
and also
during the pandemic this was all during
the pandemic yeah like it was born late
2019
there was a very constant environment of
practically only the parents
and we knew when there were changes in
context and you see at the beginning the
kid was speaking more spanish horse and
german
and
it really you can really see it in the
acceleration of the vocabulary spur that
it starts really going very very fast
until we have a
change in the alternate side so
um
i had started working again
and my wife's at home and she was mostly
speaking um german and so the spanish
slope uh sold down
then
first it slowed down and then it
completely
dropped um
with
was starting to drop really quickly
until my parents came to this
and it was the first time
that the kid was in a situation when
there were people that could not
understand german so
the slowing down was uh was uh stopped a
bit and you see the the
the the picture in the gown in german
german took a while to recover but it
did when they have started
uh i was having like a a normal pace
until
the labor was visited again so
it's very funny how you can really see
the peaks and the change of context
and this was all all fun about the total
number of words
but then i started uh wondering okay so
what about the kind the type of words
so i want to take a look now at the
morphology and syntax yeah because at
the beginning kids started talking only
with pronouns saying like bomb water and
the moon and i want to eat this yeah so
lots of nouns
uh some interjections interjections are
things like no and yes and oh like
one word things that um
have the meaning of complete
sentence and i i wanted to see
how the others also
started appearing
and i have to be honest i started also
trying to lock that when i was
logging the data but
yeah at some point i i didn't know
anymore i mean this is this word like
and actually is just a pronoun a noun
luckily there are tools for that
and i took the words through
spacey and spacey has a has a property
to give you part of speech category
supports
and from that i could i could see i
could assign a category to each of the
words
so we have
um adjectives opposition adverse
auxiliaries etc yeah
um
[Music]
and then i could
track the appearance of these things
so we had first proper nouns
then nouns
then adjectives adverbs and
interjections and if i was in the room
now
i would ask you now what do you think
came
next
because when i was doing the analysis
the
my my guess was
verbs right
but actually verbs took like five more
months to come and that's because in
german there is like a weird
thing that are the verb particles
and that's why like when you say like um
to
close
the the particle is a two yeah and
little kids at the bedding just use the
particles
not the the whole the whole thing
and this made actually he made use of
this german thing to uh
to not having be able to uh or
having been forced to learn the verbs
um
so he started with with pronouns and
numbers
and then really months months later
using actually verbs
then auxiliary verbs verbs that like
serve mostly the grammar right if you're
like
ich
then
i mean this is already a bit complex
because you have you're using the
auxiliaries and the buildings it's just
like
just a burp
um then we have some particles
conjunctions and at the very end
propositions and
actually also talking to linguists they
were telling me with that acquisition of
this conjunctions and proposition
this very first phase of language that
musician is um is completed
and you may think we have all parts but
there's also something missing coming at
the very end
the articles yeah so daddy
which is super funny because it also
tells you
what importance they have in the whole
communication and it's actually very
encouraging for all of us that don't
have german and murder on and after
20 years still make mistakes in articles
um
yeah and when you see the sum
of of wars of this certain category
you see how of course the
nouns and verbs are
are are the the ones that explode also
in the vocabulary spur
but around 18 19 20 months you have this
this little
little
particles um particles auxiliaries
conjunctions appearing
and this also corresponds to my uh to my
amateur
marking of
as a milestone the kid now speaks in
sentences yeah so you have to collect
not only enough enough
vocabulary nouns and verbs etc but
really also
propositions and some conjunctions to um
to build sentences
um
can you still hear me alex would say see
you there so yeah
yeah we can hear you we can see
everybody is pretty stunned about your
talk i think that's right i cannot hear
you but i'm assuming you can give me a
thumbs up
yeah good okay
good so
that was that
and there was just one column missing
and that was
semantics
and here i also had a question for the
audience that right now that my audience
is alex because i can see him so i'm not
going to ask him here
one two or three
how many of these thousand words do you
think were
unique concepts yeah so things that the
the
the kid was
not repeating both languages
like if he had
the whole vocabulary doubled in both
languages it would be 50 yeah they would
say like the kids cannot speak thousand
concepts but only
500 in two languages right so 50
or more than 60 percent like or like 90
what do you think alex one two or three
oh me uh i can ask her who thinks first
you give me a sign because i can i
cannot hear you
ah okay that's strange okay so
few
fifty so what oh it's mixed in the
audience sixty percent
okay
um ninety percent are unique okay
ninety
ninety percent yeah are you nice that's
a major vote okay good
actually i thought yeah that's what what
people think okay
i was guessing at the beginning with 50
because the kid was speaking lots of
spanish lots of english
then when i when i asked my linguistic
friend she felt like yeah maybe
maybe 60 are unique yeah
most of it should be doubled uh and some
very specific boards shouldn't
but indeed
i saw that 90
were unique yeah so
he was only repeating
some of the words in both languages some
of the concepts were double
um
i said like well that's that's weird i
mean first of all i mean then
why why is this
and
then why the double works
and
again remember the kid is mostly at home
and both parents speak both languages
and here in this this graph you see
the appearance of
the
the moment of appearance of the of the
first time
the word was spoken
and connected
to the to the direction until the next
language
was spoken and
the first thing we see is that at the
beginning it took a while until he was
repeating concepts yeah so he was first
learning the concept and it took a long
while
at the end it's very very fast at the
end he was practically learning the
concepts both in one
at the same time
um
and then i was thinking okay but then
why is he repeating words if
if we're both speaking both languages
um and then i had the hypothesis that i
had that it's it's phonetics yeah
so the beginning he was
learning practically everything first in
in spanish
everything but the complicated spanish
words like
pelota which is ball is bal in german
that's easy right or
oh ho which is very complicated yeah
it's
for the for the baby speech is easier
and
heist is also way easier than taliente
with three syllables yeah
um
[Music]
so but this also shows i mean along the
concept that it's not the the fact that
it's not many repeated words yeah it's
that
is showing that like it is first
choosing somehow
to expand the semantic space
um and then to actually to actually
double them and
if i already had
the the words
translated to english to do this to do
this analysis then i thought well then
then i might as well take a look at the
semantic space
and this is like the last part yeah so
i took the english translation got word
vectors out of it made a pca
and here you see the first two
components that it's only like 12 of the
variance explained but
still i mean you have to to know that
word vectors have like 300 features yeah
and
but you see nicely actually how
uh how they are still like clustering
around concepts yeah so it is a real
space where you have like
the the proper the the nouns you have
all things related to um
food which is apparently very important
very important for all of you that have
small children all all animals
and then body parts are around here and
then objects and things like this and
more abstract things like feelings and
and here are some addictive and so on
and
if we take a look at all of this
over time
you can see how in this
the kid starts with mom and then it
starts expanding all over the space yeah
and then it starts repeating yeah so
it's really
first
conquering yeah with the different parts
and then having the other concepts on
top
so
uh this this was yeah very very nice
very nice
okay so wrapping up
it's only thousand words yeah a thousand
words and a few um data analysis uh
magic skills with with some nlp but you
have i mean you learn a lot and also
talking to my linguist friends like well
you can start doing like great
hypothesis out of the thing also about
bilingual
language acquisition and the advantages
of it a topic that in germany is super
super important yeah so in the kita of
my kid
i think there are
four out of 25 kids that are not growing
up bilingual or would have the chance
um
but of course you need to gather the
data and no no researcher can do that
yeah um and we're thinking this is
actually a very nice project to
have together with a call for citizen
science you know
ask around who can
who can help who wants to help
and make a little research project out
of that i'll start by putting this on on
streamlid i guess so that everybody can
just upload their data and take a look
at the charts and and then we'll see
from there
with this i am
finishing so i'm
open for questions comments and
everything you can find me on github on
twitter
and very very very hopefully at the next
meet up
thanks a lot for listening
yes so
i'm not sure if you can hear me paula
i think maybe it's you're presenting
maybe i'm using i don't hear you alex i
don't know if i must yeah because of the
screen thing i think you have to
disconnect me
okay so
um i don't know why uh so
thank you very much
thank you yeah
have a nice meet up everybody and have
some um
um some vegetables and grilled cheese
for me okay
see you
bye